tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo nuovo
video sono qua vj ed oggi ragazzi parte
il primo episodio di the in testa su
cartoon network del quale vi avevo
parlato per chi non lo sapesse
praticamente ragazzi ogni primo
mercoledì del mese
farò praticamente un episodio ho dato
una gomitata la scrivania mi sono
ammazzato farò un episodio dove giocherò
i videogame di cartoon network del mese
quindi per questo si chiama game tester
del mese e in genere potrebbero essere
due o tre forze anche quattro non lo so
dipende anche ragazzi oggi si comincia e
quindi sigla
porca vacca che c'è una sigla è
bellissimo come primo gioco proprio fare
questo che sarebbe gli eroi del ritmo
che non c'è anche fine grazie a dio
ascolta fin fi cantare film premesse lo
z cos'è cos'è no vabbè ben fatto grazie
grazie
sono incapace completa la canzone con
gli aussie carta blu allora come fa con
la mano ragazzi seguite il beat
io non ho mai visto un dj così c'è io
applausi e mi piace solo per il dj
volevo fare vedere ballare tutti qua
perché c'è un rossetto che balla aiuto
sta succedendo là mi parlate sopra
ballate che sta urlando come un idiota
come sempre meglio di come canto io ai
ragazzi che assicura ragazzi dj fa vj
presto in consolle
comunque complimenti al taglio dei
capelli del dj che la roba più bella che
abbia mai visto
game over punteggi così è il mio voto è
perché sarebbe fd fabi j passiamo ed
altro che è meglio chelsea è rotto di un
set che bello tra l'altro j
mi dà quella carica j che ogni volta che
lo vedo nuova partita o no non meno
magico ha lanciato la maledizione ajay
che un agente sta cadendo a pezzi aiuti
c'è il causa dei suoi arti rimovibili
per trovare il cappello dell'omino
magico di benassi dalla maledizione ma
donne cosa è bello va bene
proviamoci legal gioca dai che bravo di
in testa perché sono lesionati a
cliccare il tasto gioca ragazzi allora
facciamo perché quando james alta si
sente il verso del maiale vabbè è musica
messi e quindi devo riuscire a
raggiungere il cappello fantastico di
mio obiettivo è quello di prendere il
cappello insomma ogni volta a down again
che scalatore professionista non troppo
professionista sono riuscito a morire in
un livello così ragazze rendetevi conto
la roba mai vista livello successivo dai
questo mi sono artifici ha spazio per
staccare una yaeko ha inizio a staccarmi
gli arti perfetto ma cosa sa cos'è ma
perché mi devo staccare le braccia fammi
capire che senza perché devo tenerlo
attaccato prendo il mio braccio la gamba
scusami la butto giù le gambe nella vita
sono futili
va bene così perfetto bravo j
complimenti quando devo staccarmi colpi
che non mi rimane solo la testa
proprietà tra ragazzi
frega niente di staccarsi gli arti a lui
è contento non amano mi sto usando il
deretano ragazzi tranquilli la testa la
testa è bellissima non farei tutti i
livelli con la testa se potessi è la
madonna
cos'è sta cosa devo staccarmi gli arti
perché se va bene anche sherlock holmes
i livelli lega a ok prima questo che gli
altri che non ama mi sa che genio
mamma mia quanta roba rega quanta roba
se in duomo senza gli arti tranne un
braccio era che carino della mia vita
proprio mi mancava questa cosa padrona
va la mazza è diventato sono giochi per
bambini come è possibile che siano così
incasinate o sono io scemo
ah già ok non sa niente questo ragazzi
al livello 7 più di a livello 7 non
possiamo andare avanti perché il livello
7 il massimo di qualsiasi cosa nella
vita
ok a ocado farmi la scala fanta bravo
staccati le gambe così salti call call
coccige bravissimo come corda il
rimbalzo con le chiappe ragazza
meravigliosa accion braccio bravo zio
che è bravissimo bravissimo ci abbiamo
fatto 17 secondi non è male non è male
ragazzi può migliorare è però va verso
uno scemo quindi va bene anche così
vabbè proviamo entrare qua dentro
ragazzi avevo sfanò che figo lo sparare
i miei arti del tipo come si spara così
alla madonna che mira ai vai vai verrai
perfetto allora sì ma io posso entrare
nel cannone fantastico nola vero film
ragazzi io mi ricordo che da bambino si
giocava ai giochi di cartoon network e
riuscivo ad esso che ciò vent'anni come
possibile mai nella vita
ci provo lo stesso che ti vuol dire beh
è quando la propaggine si fa sentire
era un livello facile in mezzo a tutto
lo schifo perché vogliono convincerti
che adesso sia facile però poi un casino
ho capito tutto non affermi la gara oggi
ho già capito da mettere tutto quanto va
dentro passo di qua adesso sparare e
passare la barriera subito così mi
riprendo le robe credo è sì però magari
se abbas mamma mia che idiota dai zio
eccolo perfetto ce l'ho fatta e adesso
che ho scoperto che posso dimettermi gli
arti e se più semplice prima non lo
sapevo
che bello quando un livello ti riesce
perché capisci cosa devi fare e
bellissimo una volta ogni mille capita
pro capite 19 al ragazzo ali ne mancano
due che io che io che ci sono ci sono
quindi io metto la gamba qua che sto
facendo i miei ragionamenti da
psicopatico terminati ed è adesso ho
vinto se faccio così tu no perché sono
un idiota
devo prima sala stacco seguitemi e non
so se funziona stacco questo metto qui
facendo cose e non sto capendo neanche
io allora questo che questo lo rimetto
qui questa rimetto qua adesso dovrebbero
scontr assicurare alle due gambe se non
sbaglio madonna madonna va proprio è
uscito dallo schermo il livello di frasi
sta uscendo livello leggere che
all'ultimo livello del videogame se
riesco a farlo ma non credo però va bene
ma ho capito da una gamba deve andare
qua per forza no sono incastrato ma come
fatti incastrarmi cosa fa ma che fa dai
che sto cercando di finire livello
niente questa ricapitolando questo va
dentro ok ok ho capito
e c'è e c'è manca tutto il resto però
darle di qua non lo so ragazzi se
funziona ci prova proviamoci va a cagare
devi andare a destra o cliccato il tasto
di windows si è chiuso tutto porca vacca
mi sono fatto prendere dall'adrenalina
del momento e sono morto come un
deficiente prove ragazza il ragazzo ce
la sto facendo ce la posso fare me lo
sento adesso provo a fare non lo so
ragazzi non ne ho idea se metto questo
qui poi si spinge e se si spinge crea un
innesco che praticamente grazie alla
teoria di einstein del quanti di spazio
però ci provo tanto ormai
ragazzi miei siamo in dirittura d'arrivo
bravo jcr ragazzuoli miei chi è il genio
quindi torna europea 20 anni e mezzo per
far questo livello però maturazioni hai
rotto la maledizione ha imparato a una
grande lezione come costruire un razzo
interspaziale perché la difficoltà era
quel bambino magico e un gran
rompiscatole goditi i tuoi akin goditi i
tuoi alti mentre le continue lanciare le
sue maledizioni va bene lagarde ragazzi
ho finito jake si è rotto cosa
incredibilmente incredibile con quello
che l'episodio è spero che vi sia
piaciuto anche perché è una serie nuova
di sei episodi che andrò a fare ogni
primo mercoledì del mese
l'ho detto all'inizio praticamente
questo video quale potete vedere anche
sul sito di cartoon network sul canale
degli di cartoon network di youtube che
vi lascio in descrizione e anche su
cartoon network proprio perché lo
daranno su cartoon network anche che è
una cosa troppo oddio sono sono in
tv devo dire qualcosa di figo perché
sono in televisione non posso lasciarmi
scappare questa cosa
banana non troppo storta i ragazzi
conclusione vi ricordate ogni mese e
sceglierò il game tester del mese perché
se volete potete fare anche voi un
gameplay come il mio se volete provarci
ragazzi vi lascio l'info in descrizione
io comunque concluso qui episodio spero
che vi sia piaciuto è come se sì vi è
piaciuto
dovevo prendere fiato la scelta come te
mi piace anche la pagina di facebook con
i video torna letizia nei servizi di 16
miliardi